So we looked at that program,
what it does, what input it takes,
how does it execute on the different
values for the input that we provide it.
But to really understand how we actually
take this buffer overflow to its
logical conclusion, which is actually
getting control of this program.
We need to actually look carefully
at how data is stored on the stack.
What is the layout of the stack?
So remember I told you the stack grows
from high addresses to low addresses.
So we are at some address, and
as you put more stuff on it,
we are going to lower addresses.
So as we go down the stack,
as we push things on to the stack,
we get to lower and lower addresses and
that's what I meant by the stack
growing from high addresses to
low addresses or growing up few.
Think of your address base starting
at zero and going to the max.
Then the stack growth is from
higher to lower addresses.
And lower addresses are higher or up.
So that's why we're saying
it grows in that direction.
So when you make the function call,
we're going to push the arguments argcr,
with the arguments.
So we are assuming this is
what the compiler does.
You make a function call in
your programming language.
First thing it does it's going to push.
So wherever stack pointer is pointing,
we push this argument
that takes 4 bytes.
So the place it points to the address
where the stack pointer is pointing is
address 4 addr- 4.
Then we push argv and at this point
we have to push the return address.
Remember we have to know where
the return address is, so
when we finish executing this function
we can go back to where we came from.
You then push the return address, so
the compiler generates code
to push the arguments.
And then you make a function call or
you make a call.
And typically the hardware
pushes the return address onto
the stack wherever the stack
pointer is pointing.
That goes and then we get to the stack
pointer and we decrement the stack
pointer by 4 because the return
address [INAUDIBLE] takes 4 bytes.
So now we're going to allocate space for
the local variables,
allowlogin takes four bytes.
12 bytes strings take 12
bytes that we have here.
So each of password string and
target password we have 12 bytes each.
So, you made the call, if the stack
pointer was pointing to Addr,
then I can say, well the address
of allowed login is Addr-12
because 4 for argc, 4 for
argv, 4 for return address.
Already occupied these 12 locations, so
the stack pointer has
to move beyond those.
And it does that by
moving 12 bytes up and
as it goes up to lower addresses,
we're doing the subtraction that I said.
So, now if you look here there's
a couple of interesting things.
This is password string isn't it?
It's allocated space starting here.
If it's less than 12 bytes,
the input we provide,
it's going to stay within these 12
bytes that we allocated for it.
So this is the starting address, so
if the variable is that address,
address +1, +2,
it goes like that every byte you store.
So these are the higher
addresses we were talking about.
So, password strings start here,
if it's less than 12 bytes,
it's only going to go
into these 12 bytes.
What happens if it's
longer than 12 bytes?
Some of the examples that we
did when we set it to 16 or
something like that,
it's going to exhaust these 12 bytes.
It's going to overwrite
the allowlogin and
if it's more than 16
what is it going to do?
It's going to overwrite
the return address.
So the way these things
are let out on the stack,
remember our password string
variable address starts here.
And as we provide some number of
characters it starts storing them.
If they're less than 12 we're good.
If they're more than 12 we're first
going to overwrite allow login.
Then we're going to
overwrite return address.
Then we're going to corrupt the argument
values and things like that.
Now we can say well,
what if I give more than 12 bytes.
We earlier said 16 or
ending whatever it is.
We know that if it's more than 12,
it's going to all flow into this.
This is what it is going to all flow as.